hi there steve kaufman here sitting in
my yard here in palm springs and again
talking about language learning
and i'm going to follow up on my
discussion last week about input and
about motivation and i'm going to make
some reference to
taoism or taoism and zhuangza and
certain
sort of aspects of eastern philosophy
and how i feel that it relates to
acquiring a skill like a language
so
i mentioned last time that uh stephen
krashen had said that motivation is not
the way we get people to learn because a
majority of
children in school are not particularly
motivated to learn
and we have to kind of grab them with
interesting compelling content and of
course that is true
however
i find as a learner
that i can vary the interesting and i
need to have that interesting compelling
content
i did an interview for example this
morning in russian
[Music]
i just said that i gave an interview in
russian and everything was fairly well
understood between what my russian
counterpart had to say which i
understood entirely and of what i had to
say
all the while aware of my mistakes but
it doesn't matter
so
um
the point i wanted to make was with the
russian is that my motivation to learn
russian was the desire and this came up
in our discussion was the desire to read
the works of russian literature in the
original
and i was asked like why was this a
motivation and i said well
because the sense of reading these works
in the original
a gives you a sense of achievement and
gives you a sense of something special
you're in touch with the original it's a
wonderful feeling so that was my
motivation not everyone is motivated
that way
but if i look at my greek
again motivated to learn about greek
history about you know discovering that
that large part of the history of the
world when greeks were dominant from
about
uh you know at least in the eastern
mediterranean world from al even you
know from
pericles the building of the acropolis
and alexander the great the whole
biblical period when greek was the
dominant language
constantinople or at least emperor
constantine moved the roman empire
capital to constantinople then we had
byzantium byzantium which in turn
influenced the religions and much of the
art and so forth of the eastern of
eastern europe and russia and so forth i
mean it's a major major chunk of of uh
certainly european history and so i was
motivated to to read out read up about
that in greek and when i now can read
something that was written in ancient
greek and i at least can you know make
out the sound even though the language
is different all of that is tremendously
motivating
but
and it's compelling however i'm also
capable of listening to these mini
stories which are repetitive they use a
lot of the most common vocabulary the
vocabulary repeats in each story and and
i can tell from my statistics at link
that i have listened to these stories
you know my statistics say 50 times but
i listen on my mp3 player without it
showing up in my statistics so it's got
to be a hundred times each story
i don't listen to them a hundred times
at a shot i listen to it once i go
listen to something else maybe other
stories maybe i read about the acropolis
or listen to my podcast then i come back
to these many stories
and i'm able to do that because it is
it is relatively easy to do it's
compelling it's repetitive repetitive
the person's voice is pleasing
and it's it's um
you know it's like like training for
judo or or
for whatever it's this repetitive
exercise it's like going to the gym to
train
it's not the game the game is listening
to something that's interesting but it's
repetitive and every time i listen i
discover something that i missed the
previous time
and and i think actually even in a
class situation you know kids will do
what they're assigned to do so they will
listen to these simple stories
uh
to some extent and and to me it's a
little bit like the sort of uh
call it you know like the taoist
traditions of of chinese
you know literature or philosophy
uh
and which we can see in to some extent
in how like some of the you know the
martial arts how this constant
repetition of basic forms and and
patterns are repeated and repeated and
repeated until it becomes second nature
and it reminds me if i remember
correctly the story drunks are told of
this butcher who was butchering an ox
for the duke of when or whatever it
might be
and he explained that he just been doing
it for so long that that the first year
it was more difficult and by the third
year he no longer saw
the whole ox he saw where the tendons
and where where the bones were and and
because he had such a natural feel to
how of how to butcher the ox therefore
he didn't need to force it didn't he
need to force the knife and it's this
idea that we learn things through
getting used to them
through repetition
not through some theoretical explanation
and i think the the sort of repetitive
listening and particularly listening as
well as reading
uh more simple material blended in with
the more compelling content is an
important part of language learning and
now how much time i spend on
compelling content how much i spend on
this sort of repetitive content it's
more a matter of of my mood of the
moment and i think that that again is
important that we be guided by
our interest because we have to enjoy
the process so we i've you know
it is easy to listen to the simple
stories it's easier to listen to simple
stories when i'm exercising for example
in the car
i'm happier listening to interesting
content because i'm able to focus a
little better if i'm doing push-ups
it's better just to have these
repetitive stories going in the
background
but again it's something that we need to
decide for ourselves
uh
so i just want to make the point and and
and when i say repetitive it doesn't
mean that you should listen to the same
story over and over and over again i get
questions often like should i stay on a
bit of content until i have it 100
no
move on
and you should look forward to when you
can come back to that simple story and
the next time you'll pick up something
that you didn't get the previous time so
there will still be words that you may
have learned and subsequently forgotten
uh there'll be aspects of the grammar
that you may have noticed and
subsequently forgotten and you go back
and you listen to the same thing for the
80th time and you always pick up
something new so i think a regime of a
mixture of repetitive listening uh with
the compelling
compelling content is important and it
should be interleaved it's a term i've
used before
but it certainly has its role and it
does tie in and the reason i raise it
again is because it does tie into this
this sense of of learning through
through getting used to something which
is very much a part of of the sort of
zen and taoist
tradition of
of eastern philosophy so just wanted to
pass that on uh i hope that's uh
useful and i look forward to your
comments and if you like these videos
please subscribe bye for now
[Music]
you